bitcoin is absolutely ripping we cross
over 57 000 this morning and when you
start to look at the underlying data it
is telling us that it is likely to go
much much higher through the end of the
year when we actually look at the first
chart that we have here bitcoin over 57
500 it's up about four percent today the
first thing that jumps out to me when we
look at these charts is that now a four
percent move in bitcoin means that
bitcoin is moving thousands of dollars
in a single day likely we will start to
see ten percent movements as well but a
four percent leap much much more
volatile than anything else in this
chart s p gold silver euro yen renin b
or the oil now on top of this people
always argue that bitcoin is too
volatile that is one of the critiques
from the critics but what they failed to
mention is that bitcoin's volatility
works in both directions if you are
holding bitcoin and bitcoin is volatile
to the downside it hurts you it's a
negative but if you are holding bitcoin
and bitcoin is volatile to the upside
the volatility is your friend and that's
what we're watching right here 2
227 increase in the price of bitcoin
over the last 24 hours volatility is
good when it goes in your favor when we
start to look at the actual underlying
metrics of the uh uh network you can see
the bitcoin market cap is over one
trillion dollars 1.08 trillion dollars
as of this morning on top of that the
inflation rate still is at 1.78 percent
well below the fed's target of 2 percent
in the u.s dollar system the supply
issued 89.7
bitcoins settlement volume has topped 11
billion
one day last week bitcoin saw over 30
billion dollars settled on chain pretty
impressive it was an all-time high still
though in the double-digit tens of
billions of dollars for on-chain
settlement the real exchange volume
right around 8 billion
over 800 000 active addresses and then
the miners the miners absolutely coming
in with a monster number miners have
been paid 52 and a half million dollars
in the last 24 hours to secure the
bitcoin network the bitcoin network is
the strongest most decentralized
computer network in the world and the
reason why so many people are putting
their computing power on the bitcoin
network to secure it to validate
transactions and to ensure the stable
sustainable resilient network is because
there's a 52 million dollar daily reward
right now for anyone who's doing that
pretty incredible when we then go and we
look at bitcoin compared to the s p and
gold we can see that bitcoin is now up
over 400 percent in the last year it's
up over 8 900 percent in the last five
years and it is up over 1.4
million percent over the last 10 years
now when you compare bitcoin's 400
increase to gold gold is down 9 on a
nominal basis which means that gold is
actually down on a real return basis 14
bitcoin up over 400 gold down 14
and when you look at the real return
basis and so bitcoin has absolutely
taken the place of gold as an inflation
hedge asset and institutional and retail
investors have dumped gold over the last
12 months even though the macro
environment called for interest rate
manipulation down and also historic
level of quantitative easing when we
look at the s p 500 a 25 percent gain
more than 2x the
national average or the historic average
i'm sorry 25 percent being 2x what
normally would occur but
still dwarfed in comparison to bitcoin
at over 400 percent when we look at the
bitcoin price and the closing history
this is one of the most interesting
things right now is that bitcoin's price
has only been higher than 57 500 29 days
of its entire existence which is 0.62
of its entire life since january 3rd
2009 and so if you bought bitcoin 99.38
of bitcoin's life and you held it till
today your purchasing power has
appreciated compared to other assets
where the purchasing power of the
currencies where the purchasing power
decreases bitcoin's purchasing power has
increased over the last 12 years or so
and so
99.38 i don't do public math but i think
that's right of the time bitcoin's
purchasing power has increased when we
look at the bitcoin versus other assets
like gold s p 500 nasdaq or treasuries
we also can see that the roi again 400
percent you can see things like tlt is
down 11.6 which is pretty crazy the
compound annual growth rate of bitcoin
today comes in over the last 10 years at
161
161 compounded annually for a decade
absolute monster numbers and then if you
look at the sharpe ratios over one in
five years bitcoin denomina or
dominating the rest of the financial
markets absolutely destroying anything
else bitcoin has proven to become that
apex predator of financial markets but
bitcoin is not only a financial asset
something that you buy and hope for
financial performance michael saylor
over the weekend had a great tweet that
really explained and highlighted the
value of bitcoin he said bitcoin is
superior due to engineering not
tribalism the protocol is better suited
to organic growth of a decentralized
network with integrity and security
across political jurisdictions the
stability of the base layer drives
faster innovation in the application
layers above and so bitcoin is not just
an asset that you can buy and hold a
global store of value something that is
censorship resistant but it is also a
payment rail and a decentralized
platform of which applications will be
built on top of it we've seen everything
from the lightning network to other
applications but what michael is
specifically talking about here is the
engineering superiority the ability for
it to be suited for organic growth a
decentralized network with integrity and
security across any jurisdiction it
solely exists in cyberspace in the
virtual economy somewhere that is not
tied to a physical jurisdiction and the
stability of the base layer drives that
faster innovation of anything that is
built on top of it now it is of course
well understood that people in the
retail market people in the financial
market and also folks who have been
building in and around the bitcoin and
crypto industry understand this asset
they understand how it works and they
understand what the financial elements
of it are but one person that you
probably would not expect to really
understand it is politicians and what we
saw last week at the texas blockchain
summit was ted cruz standing on stage or
sitting on stage giving a talk about
bitcoin and he had very articulate take
nick carter went ahead and transcribed
the entire uh talk but what i wanted to
do is i want to call it a very specific
part at one point ted cruz said it's a
weird point a lot of the discussion
around bitcoin views bitcoin as a
consumer of energy a lot of the
criticism directed at it is the
consumption of energy the perspective
i'm suggesting is very much the reverse
which is a way to strengthen our energy
infrastructure and it also has one of
the most exciting things about crypto is
the ability to unlock stranded
renewables so there are a lot of places
on earth where the sun shines a lot and
the wind blows a lot but there aren't
any power lines and so it's not
economically feasible to use that energy
and the beauty of bitcoin mining is that
if you can connect to the internet you
can use that energy and derive value
from those renewables in a way that
would be impossible otherwise and i
think we're going to see in the next
five years massive innovations in that
regard as well it is incredible to see a
sitting politician articulate bitcoin
bitcoin mining and its interfacing with
the energy grid in such a great way he
obviously understands the value of
bitcoin mining and he sees how bitcoin
is not simply a high consumer of
electricity but rather bitcoin can serve
as a great catalyst for growth
investment and build out of energy
infrastructure and so whether you're
looking at bitcoin as a financial asset
whether you're looking at as an
engineering feat or whether you are
looking at it as its positive impact on
the energy grid or other parts of our
non-bitcoin lives when you start to
understand is we are watching an asset
grow from the corners of the internet
into the mainstream to be repriced by
markets and to capture the imagination
of the entire world
that is what bitcoin is doing right
before us and people are looking and
saying hey it went up a little bit it
went down a little bit but they're
losing the bigger picture bitcoin has
now reached the mainstream and we are
likely to continue to see a drastic
increase in the adoption of the asset
not only from individual investors not
only from institutions like financial
institutions and corporations and not
only from nation states like el salvador
and maybe brazil and others but bitcoin
is also becoming an asset that is
penetrating every industry on earth
we're seeing the oil and gas the
capitalism of america start to embrace
this and i don't think it's going to
stop anytime soon